qu'est ce que j'ai fait avec ça devra
préparer un iphone oui cette scène
pourrait se produire dans n'importe
quelle boulangerie en france mais nous
sommes en israël dans la ville de
netanya
il ya sept ans hélène a quitté la
bretagne s'est installé ici avec sa
famille non sans difficultés les deux
premières années on a pas on a travaillé
comme ça indépendamment moi j'ai fait
des ménages chez les périodes chez les
personnes âgées je me suis au pied des
personnes âgées mon mari a travaillé
dans un supermarché où il a fait de la
mise en place la mise en rayon la nuit
et on a fait ça pendant deux ans mais je
me suis posé beaucoup de questions je me
suis dit c'est difficile le train de vie
beaucoup plus difficile et c'est vrai
qu'on s'est posée dès fois la question
est ce que ce serait pas mieux de
retourner mais pour les enfants la
vérité non cette ville particulièrement
prisée par les français surnommé la côte
d'azur israélienne certains magasins
affichent la couleur
et si vous poussez la porte de l'un
d'entre eux on vous accueillera dans la
langue de bois ni c'est le dernier 5,6
en plein plein plein de français chez
moi au moins en moins selon l'historien
marc nobel entre 2000 et 2010 est ce
sont plus de 55000 français qui ont
réalisé leur alya et qui sont venus
s'installer ici en israël des chiffres
en nette augmentation après les attaques
terroristes de ces dernières années un
certain nombre de ces français a décidé
de s'installer ici dans la station
balnéaire de netanya on est à 20 km au
nord de tel aviv
une ville où un habitant sur trois est
francophone
demain soir nord au cinéma illustration
à nouveau à la terrasse de ce café nous
retrouvons ce groupe de retraités
établie en israël depuis une dizaine
d'années il nous explique ce qui pousse
tant de juifs a quitté la france il n'y
a qu'à voir tout ce qui se passe la nuit
avec sarah le dire ça donne bien le ton
tout ce qu'il m'a délétère vécu
il est évident mais surtout on aurait en
france
moi je suis arrivé en france j'avais 4
ans donc les blues et toute ma vie j'ai
presque 60 passé toute ma vie en france
mais c'est impossible d'envisager de
continuer même à mon âge alors les
jeunes encore plus parce que c'est ce
qui va se passer
qu'est-ce qui va passer ils vont faire
comment 36 si vous commencez à les
casser du juif par tous ceux ressentis
et partager unanimement par la
communauté française de netanya ici tout
le monde a une mauvaise expérience à
raconter
c'est le cas dylan à agent immobilier
installé ici depuis trois ans et ce qui
m'a fait le déclic c'est les événements
qui a eu avec charlie hebdo avec le
bataclan et que j'ai entendu dans les
métros je prenais le métro en soif
l'entrée du travail et j'ai entendu à
mort les juifs avec un caissier et ce
jour là ça a été fatal je me suis dit je
vais pas je devais me marier et je vais
si dieu voilà avoir des enfants et je
vois pas mes enfants vivent dans un
monde comme ça et donc ça m'a fait ce
déclic et j'ai dit allez on y va
je regarde un peu d'informations
internationales mais lié à la france
mettez ouais c'est derrière moi
complètement
je suis contente a dit quoi je rêve
d'information française qui aura pas si
mon dieu je suis partie de ces pays pour
certains le changement est trop brutal
barrière de la langue pouvoir d'achat
couverture sociale
il faut s'adapter et ils sont
quelques-uns a finalement décidé de
revenir en france mais la majorité des
nouveaux arrivants français de netanya
reste ici
donnant à cette ville de deux cent mille
habitants des airs de bourgade française
en plein coeur du proche orient
[Musique]